Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件现在正在发生、非常令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主讲的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a memory entering Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都能为你所用。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品等你来拿。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一小时教练辅导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。节目。Without a memory entering 嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。
Thank you for listening and thank you for being part of my world. Today is episode 43 and I will level with you. This episode was always going to be happening, but this is not quite the episode I had planned. But yeah, the one I had planned is coming soon. But yeah, there's just been a slight delay. But yeah, I am today using some old footage but it's really an incredible interview that I'd done and really very interesting and it's with Harry Parekh and he is now a third year trainee whereas when we met to do the interview I believe he was getting interviews for training he might well have just been told he
感谢你的收听，也感谢你成为我世界的一部分。今天是第 43 期节目，我和大家交个底。这期节目本来是一直都要做的，但这其实并不是我原本计划的那期节目。不过，我原本计划的那期节目很快就会和大家见面。只是，嗯，稍微延迟了一点。不过，嗯，我今天使用的是一些旧素材，但这真的是一次非常不可思议的访谈，而且非常有趣。访谈对象是哈里·帕雷克（Harry Parekh），他现在是一名三年级规培生，而当我们见面做访谈时，我相信他正在参加规培面试，或者可能刚刚被通知
had a place on training actually so it was interesting to listen back to this episode because I think I've become a better podcaster over the last couple of years um and yeah just it feels like a lot has changed in my life you know since then so I've just checked and we got this published in May 2020 um so yeah it's you know coming up um almost two and a half years ago probably since we filmed it and loads has changed you know what we know is that we were in a much earlier stage of the pandemic at that time um and i um was filming on my nhs laptop at that time and then it all got stuck on there and we couldn't get it off so we could only get the sound off so um despite the fact we had filmed ourselves um it was stuck and so um we couldn't
他实际上已经获得了规培名额。所以回听这期节目很有意思，因为我觉得在过去的几年里，我成为了一名更好的播客主持人；嗯，而且，自从那时以来，我的生活好像发生了很大的变化。所以我刚刚查了一下，我们是在 2020 年 5 月发布这一期的；所以，嗯，你知道，大概是在两年半以前我们拍摄的，而且发生了翻天覆地的变化。你知道，我们所知道的是，当时我们正处于大流行的早期阶段；而且我当时是在我的 NHS 笔记本电脑上拍摄的，然后所有东西都卡在里面了，我们无法导出来，所以我们只能导出声音。所以，嗯，尽管我们拍了视频，但它卡住了，所以，嗯，我们无法
we couldn't access the video um and so it was um yeah just audio only um and we're keeping it audio only today because I don't have any additional video, but you can definitely watch it on YouTube. If you do like to access your podcasts that way, there will be a blog post coming soon as well. But it's not quite ready yet, but it will be coming soon. So I thought this was a really interesting episode to bring to your awareness as aspiring psychologists, because the term apostate wasn't one that I was aware of. And it's a hidden research population, but also potentially a hidden trauma population too. So I won't say too much more about it. But I hope you find this really interesting and really
我们无法访问视频，所以，嗯，它就是，嗯，只有音频。我们今天也继续保持纯音频，因为我没有任何额外的视频，但你绝对可以在 YouTube 上观看。如果你喜欢通过这种方式收听播客，稍后也会有一篇博客文章发布。不过它还没完全准备好，但很快就会推出。所以我觉得这是一期非常有趣的节目，应该让身为有抱负的心理学家的你们了解，因为“背叛宗教者”（apostate）这个词并不是我以前知道的词。这是一个隐藏的研究群体，但也可能是一个隐藏的创伤群体。所以我不多说了。但我希望你觉得这非常有趣、非常
inspiring so I will catch you on the other side. Right so hi I'm Dr Marianne Trent and I'm a clinical psychologist. I've got a keen interest in research and I spotted some really interesting research just yesterday actually and it got me very excited and so I reached out to the person that's written the research and he's here with me today. I'll let him introduce himself. Hi my name is Harry Parekh. I wrote the research study on apostates as a hidden population of abuse victims which was published in January of this year. I've got around four years experience working in psychology so yeah I've got my stripes. Okay, honestly I'm so excited to speak to you. I predominantly worked in adult
鼓舞人心，我们稍后见。好的，嗨，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名临床心理学家。我对研究有着浓厚的兴趣，就在昨天，我发现了一项非常有趣的研究，这让我感到非常兴奋，于是我联系了这篇研究的作者，他今天来到了我的现场。我让他自己做个自我介绍。嗨，我叫哈里·帕雷克。我撰写了关于将背叛宗教者作为虐待受害者隐藏群体进行的研究，该研究于今年 1 月发表。我在心理学领域大约有四年的工作经验，所以，是的，我已经积累了经验。好的，说实话，我真的很高兴能和你交谈。我主要从事成人
mental health but also children and families so I was surprised to learn of a really big interesting word that I had no idea what it is even to look at it on paper I was like I don't even know how to say that can you take us through what what it is? So apostate is is a big word and it's it's the way that the it's the way that the religious kind of describe it's it's a term used by the religious to describe people raised within religious families who once identified as religious, but have now ceased to believe in the existence of God, gods, or follow that religious belief. So, and then they now identify as non-religious. So it's the people that have gone from being religious to non-religious okay so there's not like a tick
心理健康工作，但也涉足儿童和家庭领域，所以我很惊讶地了解到这样一个宏大而有趣词汇，在纸面上看到它时，我甚至不知道它是什么，我当时甚至在想我都不知道该怎么读。你能为我们讲解一下它到底是什么吗？所以，“apostate”（背叛宗教者）是一个很大的词，它是，宗教界用它来描述一种……它是宗教界用来描述那些在宗教家庭中长大、曾经认同自己有宗教信仰，但现在不再相信上帝、诸神的存在，或者不再遵循那种宗教信仰的人的一个术语。因此，他们现在认同自己是没有宗教信仰的。所以，这是指那些从有宗教信仰变成没有宗教信仰的人。好的，所以我们看到的表格上还没有像勾选
box option on forms that we see as yet saying apostate apostate um but it's you'd sort of either you'd go for like no religion or yeah you go for no religion you go for atheist or you go for you know other um i think it's it's one of those terms which isn't really widely used or really widely recognized it's kind of used as a kind of label used by the religious to negatively sometimes associate somebody with that word so it's but the people that have gone through that process seem to have taken it on themselves and kind of okay so they're owning it they're doing it but it's actually originally was a derogatory term right that's interesting perhaps we need to think about rebranding it um but i guess whatever it is for now it's just important that we talk about it and you know for me who's um a qualified clinical
选项那样写着“背叛宗教者、背叛宗教者”的选项，但你可能会选择“无宗教”或者，是的，你选择无宗教，你选择无神论者，或者你选择，你知道的，其他……我觉得这是一个没有被广泛使用或广泛认可的术语。它有点被宗教人士用作一种标签，有时带有贬义地将某人与这个词联系起来。所以，经历过这个过程的人似乎已经自己承担了这个标签，并且觉得，好吧，所以他们接纳了它，他们在这么做。但它实际上最初是一个贬义词，对吧？这很有趣，也许我们需要考虑重新包装它。但我想无论它现在意味着什么，重要的是我们谈论它，而且对于我这个……
psychologist who have never heard of this term um it was you know i'm also excited to learn new terms and new things but it feels like something i should have known about see i don't think you should have done and i think that's the beauty of it in that this is a this is a problem with hidden populations in that nobody should know nobody would know that this exists within normal kind of consensus and normal kind of conversations in the same way that all those years ago nobody knew that domestic violence was a thing nobody knew that sexual violence was a thing or on a base violence was a thing and it's the same rhetoric and going it's not a you know it's not a hindrance on on any professional to not know what it is when
从来没有听说过这个术语的合格临床心理学家来说，你知道的，我也很高兴学习新的术语和新的事物，但这感觉像是我应该知道的事情。你看，我不认为你本该知道，我认为这正是它的美妙之处，即这是一个隐藏群体的问题，没有人应该知道，也没有人会知道在常规的社会共识和常规的对话中存在着这一点，就像多年前没有人知道家庭暴力是一回事，没有人知道性暴力是一回事，或者没有人知道荣誉谋杀是一回事一样。这是同样的修辞，它不是任何专业人士不知道它是什么的阻碍，当
for example this is the first time the academic sphere can actually point themselves to an academic piece to say this exists so I would never say that a professional should have known it if anything what it does is it adds to the professional repertoire of any professional working in in the field to go oh hang on a minute are we missing something out and that's the conversation which I'm sure you're interested in um so yeah no you know no worries about not knowing it but the beauty of being a professional is that once you do know it you're like oh
例如，这是学术界第一次能够真正指出一篇学术论文来证明“这确实存在”。所以我绝不会说一个专业人士本应该知道这一点。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是它丰富了任何在这个领域工作的专业人士的专业知识库，让他们觉得：“噢，等一下，我们是不是漏掉了什么？”这就是我确信你也会感兴趣的对话。所以，嗯，是的，不知道也没关系。但作为专业人士的美妙之处在于，一旦你知道了，你就会想：“噢！”
I love that I know it so thank you for introducing that to my uh my consciousness but also it will be something that I honestly sincerely will take with me to think about with with clients regardless of their faith or current faith I guess having read your research everybody should very interesting it was really is for me it's so important to think about family systems but also family backgrounds so um you know you said that actually people who cast themselves in apostates and took part in your research um had experienced violence um from family members because of that precisely and it's you know it's the same issues that you have with
我很高兴我知道了这一点，所以谢谢你将这个概念引入我的意识中。而且这绝对将是我会真诚地带在身边、并在面对客户时去思考的问题，无论他们的信仰或当前信仰如何。读了你的研究后，每个人都会觉得非常有趣。对我来说，思考家庭系统以及家庭背景是如此重要；所以，嗯，你知道的，你刚才说过，实际上那些将自己归类为背叛宗教者并参与了你研究的人，曾因为这个原因精确地遭受过来自家庭成员的暴力。而且你知道，这和你处理
intra-familial kind of family violence it's that kind of area where you know these victims are being as their kind of terms go they're being assaulted they're being seriously assaulted and they're being psychologically abused you know the difference between the assault and the serious assault is the difference between pushed and shoved to being threatened to be killed or being threatened to be harmed with you know like a knife or a gun or something say more serious than that and psychological abuse contains a plethora of things like coercive control stress depression isolation you know neglect you know all of those kind of terms as well which we we see within the kind of clinical framework when we work you know i've got experience working with people that have been through domestic violence and it's
家族内部家庭暴力时遇到的问题是同一种问题，就是那种你知道这些受害者正在遭受——按照他们的说法——他们正在遭受袭击，他们正在遭受严重袭击，他们正在遭受心理虐待。你知道，袭击和严重袭击的区别就在于，它是被推搡抓推，还是受到被威胁杀害的威胁，或者受到诸如刀或枪之类的武器伤害的威胁。所以这比前者更严重。而心理虐待则包含了一系列的事情，比如强制控制、压力、抑郁、孤立、你知道的、忽视，以及我们在临床框架中看到的所有这些类型的术语。当我们工作时，你知道，我有过与经历过家庭暴力的人合作的经验，这与
very similar kind of notions of the things that they've gone through so yeah it's it's bringing on a seriousness in the fact that leaving a religious faith or making that decision that this perspective might not be for you has consequences that are very extreme and we need to be very aware of actually within certain frameworks how is this working when they're going to the gp when they go you know when families go into the gp with a child when they're going to hospital when they're seeing a nurse and they're seeing a midwife in all these kind of different areas or when they're going to school you know we only have to look at the kind of um we only have to look at the cases the case studies of things like victoria climbia um baby p daniel pelker in coventry you know um subji and suji atwal you
他们所经历的事情有着非常相似的概念。所以，是的，它带来了一种严肃性，即脱离一种宗教信仰，或者做出这种观点可能不适合你的决定，会产生非常极端的后果。我们需要非常清楚地认识到，在某些框架内，当他们去看全科医生时，当他们——你知道的——当家庭带着孩子去看全科医生时，当他们去医院时，当他们看护士时，当他们在所有这些不同领域看到助产士时，或者当他们去学校时，这到底是如何运作的。你知道，我们只需要看看那种……我们只需要看看诸如维多利亚·克林姆比亚（Victoria Climbié）、P宝贝、考文垂的丹尼尔·佩尔克（Daniel Pelka），你知道的，
know or shafir ahmed and look at the honor base violence within that all the different cultural and traditional issues and go people in positions of power struggle to question that why did they struggle with that and actually what's related to that we've only just got to the point now where we were able to where we've got systems in place for professionals to do that and now i'm basically saying hi you you need to add another one into that into that remit and here's something for sadly for professionals here's another there's another angle that we need to be we need to be aware of because another thing for us to think about on our training but really important to think about because you could you could imagine them going to the gp with their with their parent
苏吉和苏吉·阿特瓦尔（Sujit and Sujita Atwal），你知道的，或者沙菲尔·艾哈迈德（Shafilea Ahmed）的案例研究，看看其中的荣誉谋杀，看看所有不同的文化和传统问题，然后就会发现处于权力地位的人很难去质疑这一点。他们为什么很难质疑这一点？实际上，这与什么有关呢？我们现在才刚刚走到这一步，建立了让专业人士能够做到这一点的系统。而现在我基本上是在说：“嗨，你需要在那个职责范围内再添加一项。”而且不幸的是，对于专业人士来说，这里还有另一个我们需要注意的角度，
or with their carer and having gone through all of this stuff and not being able to voice it it's the same way as women aren't able to voice about rape or not able to voice about sexual violence or domestic violence and how do we allow that to happen yeah again one of my um clinical specialties has become working with people um who have been traumatized either through sort of type one trauma so like something extreme like a explosion or something like that but also type two traumas which would be kind of stuff that adds up that is smaller stuff or joined up or developmental trauma so stuff from their childhood uh first 18 years of life i don't know if you're aware of it but there's a scale that um is widely used um in trauma populations called the ACE so the adverse
因为这是我们在培训中需要思考的另一件事。但思考这一点非常重要，因为你可以想象他们带着父母或照顾者去看全科医生，经历这一切却无法将其表达出来。这就好比女性无法说出强奸经历、无法说出性暴力或家庭暴力一样，我们如何才能允许这种情况发生？是的，再次强调，我的临床专长之一已经变成了与那些经历过创伤的人合作，这些创伤要么是通过 1 型创伤（比如爆炸之类的极端事件），要么是通过 2 型创伤（也就是那些不断累积的、较小的、连续的或发展性创伤，即来自童年时期、
childhood experiences scale and when I was reading your research I guess I was wondering whether the people who were um in your survey whether if they'd been aced um before it's possibly in future research whether they all were how high their a score would have been anyway so whether they they're more likely to become an apostate to turn away from a family that's always been quite scary and quite controlling or whether actually maybe their ace score to the first 18 years of life maybe their a score was zero um but then the reaction to leaving the faith um has evoked this violence do you see what i mean
人生前 18 年的经历）。我不知道你是否了解，在创伤群体中广泛使用着一个量表，叫做 ACE，也就是不良童年经历量表（Adverse Childhood Experiences scale）。当我阅读你的研究时，我一直在想，那些参与你调查的人，在之前是否经历过 ACE？或许在未来的研究中，他们是否都有过这种经历，他们的 ACE 得分到底有多高？因此，他们是否更有可能成为背叛宗教者，从而背离一个一直以来都让他们感到恐惧和高度控制的家庭？或者，其实也许他们人生前 18 年的 ACE 得分是零，
yeah i think i think the the the complication of of this with an ace would be that it's not necessarily that it's through it's not necessarily that it will always be through adverse childhood experiences that somebody would therefore leave for example you could turn you know you could go through childhood completely like you know you could go through childhood completely fine and maybe then decide that actually this perspective isn't for me but the childhood was completely fair and there were no complications there and you could be an 18 year old going this isn't for me. You know, we also know of people within Jehovah's Witness communities who there was an 80 year old lady that left at 80. And she's like, I'm finally able to leave, for example.
但随后他们对离开宗教信仰的反应引发了这种暴力？你明白我的意思吗？是的，我认为，将这一点与 ACE 结合起来的复杂性在于，一个人离开并不一定总是因为经历了不良童年经历。例如，你可以度过一个非常正常的童年——你知道的，你可以安然度过童年，然后可能决定其实这种观点不适合你，但你的童年完全是公平的，没有任何复杂的状况。你完全可以是一个 18 岁的年轻人，然后说：“这不适合我。”你知道的，我们也知道耶和华见证人（Jehovah's Witness）社群里的人，有一个 80 岁的老太太在 80 岁时离开了。她说：“我终于能够离开了，例如。”
So the ace would perhaps not kind of figure out the intricacies of what constitutes somebody leaving because the aura is massive. I wonder whether it might have some predictive power for thinking about what the familial reaction would be though so it might not necessarily be a contributor to them wanting to to become an apostate but whether or not they put whether or you know it might be predicted for the violence or the hostility i think that what we what we found and what we find is that it's whether somebody makes the public announcement that they've left um whichever religious denomination um if they leave it's primarily focused on what's going to be the reaction of the family when i do it so some people care about the reaction quite a lot or some people go you know what I need to make the I need to make the call and I'm done for the people that need for the people that take a lot more thought into the reaction
所以 ACE 也许无法厘清构成一个人离开的复杂错综的原因，因为这个范畴太庞大了。不过，我很好奇它是否可能对预测家庭会做出什么反应具有一定的预测能力。因此，它可能不一定是他们想要成为背叛宗教者的促成因素，但它是否可以用来预测暴力或敌意？我认为我们所发现的，并且我们一直在发现的是，这取决于一个人是否公开宣布他们已经离开了——无论哪个宗教教派——如果他们离开，这主要取决于当我这样做时家人的反应会是什么？所以有些人非常在意这种反应，而另一些人则会想：“你知道吗？我必须做出这个决定，我受够了。”对于那些花更多时间去考虑其他人反应的人来说，
of other people there's a concern as to going you're making a decision based on you but you're adding all these factors involved to make sure that you know is the decision they're making legitimate um they weigh in and they that that ace would then have a bit of a bit of power to it then or a bit of strength to it to go well actually if the if the you know if the if the household or if the the factors within it are kind of threatening towards somebody leaving in that way then maybe this there's something in that where they would suggest that they would remain within such practices or they wouldn't challenge it or they'd find that they couldn't um which would be really useful information yeah again future research isn't it that's the joy i'd seen that in your paper you'd you'd referenced it to sort of almost be like being like coming out
会有一种担忧，即你会基于自己做出决定，但你又把所有这些涉及的因素都加了进来，以确保你所做出的决定是合理的。他们进行权衡，然后这种 ACE 在此时就会发挥一点作用或展现一点力量，即“好吧，如果家庭，或者其中的因素对某人以这种方式离开构成了威胁，那么这其中可能就有什么东西表明他们会选择继续留在这种做法中，或者他们不会去挑战它，或者他们发现自己做不到。”这将会是非常有用的信息。是的，这又是未来的研究方向，对吧？这就是乐趣所在。我看到在你的论文中，你曾引用过它，几乎就像是出柜一样，
if somebody's uh you know coming out to their family about their sexuality and sort of likened that disclosure um as becoming an apostate yeah there's um because because interestingly the notions of gender and sexuality and the the way that that is concentrated upon within kind of religious households or religious communities and the way that that's perceived especially if you're you know uh if you if you um identify as part of the LGBTQ plus range um that there's a complication there of how people might react to that now the the severity that that could bring is very similar to an apostate coming out because the sad thing is is that scriptures don't provide any leniency and neither do community structures and neither do family structures either so the severity. I'm surprised to see your appendices at the end of the research with the bits of scripture from different faiths literally saying what what
如果有人向家人出柜谈论他们的性取向，并把这种坦白比作成为背叛宗教者。是的，因为，有趣的是，性别和性取向的概念，以及在宗教家庭或宗教社群中对这一点的关注方式，以及人们对它的感知方式——尤其是如果你认同 LGBTQ+ 群体的话——这里面存在着人们如何对此做出反应的复杂性。这种反应可能带来的严重程度与背叛宗教者出柜非常相似，因为可悲的是，经文没有提供任何宽容度，社群结构也没有，家庭结构也没有。这种严重程度……我很惊讶地看到你的研究结尾附录中，有来自不同信仰的经文字句，字面意思上写着应该对那些在宗教上寻找其他出路的人做些什么。
should happen to people who who look elsewhere for religion and that's only a snapshot and that was only you know i had like i think i had like two or three pages before i brought it to vince um he's the second author who's my supervisor and i was just and he's just like you need to cut that down and just just pick the yeah there's always more to say isn't there but the word count doesn't allow it and i think that you know you we can't get away from the fact that it's written in a way where leniency is is is not there for making such a decision um and yeah we have to be aware of that but to be fair just because it's written doesn't mean we have to do so again it's looking at human
而那只是冰山一角，那只是……你知道的，我大概有两三页的内容，然后我才把它拿给文斯（Vince），他是第二作者，也是我的导师。我当时正准备……而他只是对我说：“你需要删减它，只需要挑选……”是的，总有更多的话要说，对吧？但字数限制不允许。我认为，你……我们无法回避这样一个事实，即它的书写方式使得人们在做出这样的决定时没有任何宽容的余地。是的，我们必须对此保持清醒的认识。但平心而论，仅仅因为它是写下来的，并不意味着我们就必须这样做。所以这同样是在观察人类的反应，
reaction and it's looking at, you know, with the CFT model, for example, you're looking at the threat systems of people that you're then approaching. You're looking at the way that people react to news that they weren't expecting. And factoring that is probably the biggest part of this. Yeah. So if we could have mental health professionals professions know and do one thing other than be accepting um and open without judgment is there anything you think would be useful for us to be doing or to know i mean it's it's this thing of um for example the
并且在观察，比如使用 CFT（慈悲焦点疗法）模型，你是在审视你所接触的人的威胁系统。你在观察人们对意料之外的消息做出反应的方式。将这一点纳入考量可能是其中最大的一部分。是的。所以，如果我们能让心理健康专业人员了解并做出一件除了保持接纳和无条件开放、不带判断之外的事情，你认为还有什么对我们有用的事情是我们可以做的或需要知道的？我的意思是，这就像是……例如，当我们开始这项研究时，我们所担忧的是心理学专业群体会如何看待这一点？而这一群体非常喜欢它，他们认为这非常有用。这正是我们试图表达的重点，即在此之前，也许宗教结构的运作方式，以及社群和家庭围绕宗教信仰、信念、传统、文化和价值观坚定立场的运作方式，从心理学的角度来看，简直是无价之宝。因为我这些年来共事过的许多人，甚至连这的一半都没有，你会觉得，你知道吗，如果他们拥有那种稳定水平——如果你用 CFT 术语、使用慈悲焦点疗法术语的话——如果他们拥有那种稳定感和支持感，那么实际上这会为他们未来提供至少多一点点的机会，而很多研究都会这么说。我们在某种程度上把这一点颠倒过来了，
concern when we started this was how will the psychological kind of professional population view this and this one loves it this one thinks it's really useful and that's the point in actually what we're trying to say is that up until now perhaps the way that um the structures of religion and the way that communities and families kind of assert themselves around a religious faith and belief and traditions and cultures and values, psychologically speaking, is gold dust. Because a lot of the people that I've worked with over the years don't have half of that and you think you know what having that level of stability if you use CFT terms using you know compassion focus therapy terms if they have that kind of sense of stability and support then actually that would provide them with at least a little bit more of an opportunity going forwards which is what a lot of the research would say we're kind of turning that on our on the on the on its head a little bit here where where we're saying, hang on a minute, guys. I know that all of you guys are saying
在这里我们说：“等一下，各位。我知道你们所有人都在说这些都是绝妙的东西。当它不起作用时会发生什么？”我认为正是这种视角，是学术界（甚至是心理学界）以前从未见过的。有许多活动人士谈论过这一点，但这是我们第一次在学术上可以说：“等一下，让我们质疑和批判
that this is all fabulous stuff. What happens when it doesn't work? And I think that it's that perspective that the academic sphere, even in psychology, hasn't seen before. There are plenty of activists that have spoken about it, but this is the first time academically we can say, hang on a minute, let's question and critique
这个我们认为是一件绝佳好事的完美事物。”所以这关乎我们的反思能力，即仅仅因为他们拥有家庭结构、社群结构、宗教纽带，并不意味着这必然能积极地赋能他们的未来。事实上，我们需要对此提出质疑吗？或者我们需要更深入地研究它是如何为他们运作的吗？如果在干预中有任何作用的话，我想你会欣赏它赋予你的这种额外层面的认知，即“让我们稍微深入挖掘一下，看看情况如何”。这是一个以往临床医生可能不曾拥有的角度，它赋予了我们一点附加价值和思考它的信心。是的，而且
this beautiful thing that we think is is a really good thing so it's about our ability to reflect and go just because they've got family structures community structures religious ties and doesn't mean that that that means that that's that's positively enabled going forward actually do we need to question that or do we need to look at that a little bit more in depth and how was that operated for for them um if anything within within a within intervention i think i think you could probably appreciate it gives you this extra level of going well let's just tap into that a little bit and let's see where that's at and that's that's an angle that perhaps clinicians haven't had gives us a bit of added value and a bit of confidence to think about it yeah and and the
你可以用这些方式去思考的概念，比如我们可以质疑身份认同。你知道，当你与患者合作多年时，你会学会……你知道的，你会对该患者进行个案构思，你了解他们的状态、他们为什么会处于这种境地、是什么导致了这种局面，等等。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是这为你提供了一个额外的切入角度，让你去想：“等一下，让我们……这对你来说意义重大，以什么方式？如何？这源自哪里？”事实上，我记得以前曾与一位患者合作过，她的宗教身份认同正是她所经历的家庭暴力的一部分。所以在谈论她的创伤以及家庭暴力历史的同时，你不得不去谈论
notion of you can think about it in those ways like we can question you know the the the identity you know when you're when you're working with a with a patient for example for a number of years you know you learn to you know you formulate that patient you understand the kind of how they are why they are where they are what's caused it etc if anything this gives you an extra angle within that to go hang on a minute let's just let's just this means so much to you in what way how where does that come from and actually i remember working with a patient previously and her religious identity was part of the domestic violence that she'd been through so technically having to talk having to talk about
宗教信仰，你无法将它们分开，你无法把这两者保持独立。是的，你必须弥合这一鸿沟，然后说：“实际上，你在这方面的想法和你在那方面的想法在这里吻合了，这令人担忧。”作为专业人士，我们需要具备这种能力，拥有说出“你知道的，我可以质疑那部分宗教，或者我可以质疑那部分文化，或者我可以质疑那部分传统”的信心。如果你从尊重的立场出发，我认为这是可以的，并且可以进行探究，思考它是否在让问题持续停滞。是的，我也这么认为。是的，我很感兴趣地了解到，还有一个组织为人们提供支持，所以我从来没听说过“Faith to
the religious faith at the same time we're talking about her trauma kind of trauma and domestic violence history you can't not separate you can't keep them both separate yeah you've got to bridge the gap and go well actually your thoughts on this side and your thoughts on this side kind of match up here where's that's that's that's concerning um we need to have that ability as professionals to have the confidence to say you know what i can question that religious part or i can question that cultural part and i can question that traditional part if you do it from the position of respect I think that's okay and you know inquiry and thinking about what whether it's you know keeping some of the problems stuck yeah I think so yeah yeah I was really interested to know that there's an organization as well that supports people so I'd never heard of faith to
Faithless”（信仰至背道者），但这是你在研究中也提到过的内容。是的，所以……他们作为非宗教慈善机构“英国人道主义者”（Humanism UK）的背叛宗教者服务机构运作。我目前担任他们的志愿服务经理，所以我们所做的是，我们为经历过这些经历的非宗教人士和背叛宗教者提供支持，据我所知……我们还为专业人士提供诸如安全保障培训之类的服务，我们提供……你知道的，我们去大学发表演讲以及所有类似的事情。所以我们在努力，我们在努力，希望我们的目标是……你拥有如此丰富的经验，这太棒了。谢谢你。
faithless but that's something you mentioned in your in your research as well yeah so um so they work as the apostate service for a non-religious charity humanist uk um i currently work as their volunteers manager so what we do is we support and where i know right they're always um we work to support non-religious and apostates who have gone through these experiences. I think we also provide things like safeguarding training for professionals, we provide, you know, we go to universities to deliver talks and all those kind of things so we're trying, we're trying and hopefully the aim is to... You've got such a varied experience, it's amazing. Thank you.
你知道的，我的意思是，这就是重点，我很幸运，你知道的，我最初是印度教徒，我在大学时成了一名背叛宗教者，但我没有经历论文中提出的任何不良问题。在与……当我过去负责英国人道主义者协会的学生部门时，我遇到了“Faith to Faithless”的联合创始人安蒂斯·沙姆士（Amenti Shams）和阿莉娅·萨利姆（Alia Salim），当时他们是一个独立的
You know, I mean, this is the point in that I was very lucky in that, you know, I was originally Hindu and I became an apostate at university, but I went through none of the adverse issues that are raised in the paper. Working with, when I used to run the student sector of Humus UK, I met the co-founders of Faith for Faithless who are at MTS Shams and Alia Salim and that was when they were a standalone
组织，我意识到实际上人们因为离开宗教信仰而受到虐待。这确实是事实！与此同时，我正在攻读法医和犯罪心理学硕士学位，他们就说：“你知道的，选个毕业论文课题吧，快点，找点事做，你从来不睡觉吗？”不。而且你知道的，我基本上在寻找毕业论文课题时屡屡受挫，然后文斯（Vince）就说：“你知道什么就做什么，做你喜欢的事。”然后我说：“好吧，文斯，这里有一个以前没有人研究过的领域。”我的意思是，他是个行家，他当时就说：“嗯，这勾起了我的兴趣。”也勾起了我的兴趣。
organization and I realized that actually people are being abused as a result of leaving their religious faith well this is the truth at the same time I was doing my master's in forensic and criminological psychology and they were like you know pick a dissertation topic come on find something do you ever sleep no um and you know they were basically I was failing at finding a dissertation topic and then Vincent was just like what do you know do what you know do what you enjoy and I was like well Vince here's an area that hasn't been looked at before. And I mean, he knows his stuff and he was like, well, that's piqued my interest. It's piqued mine too.
多年前的那个决定让我们今天走到了一起。我们现在看的是 2015 年、2016 年，当时这还只是一篇硕士论文。所以它花了足足四五年的时间才走到发表这一步。是的，这把我们联系在了一起，哈里。和你交谈非常愉快。老实说，你给了我很多启发。所以感谢你做这项研究，同时也感谢你坚持到底，把它写出来并发表。
That decision all those years ago has led us together today. We're looking at 2015, 2016 when this was a master's thesis on its own. So it's taken a good four or five years for it to get to the point of publication. Yeah, well, it brought us together, Harry. It's been so nice to talk to you. And honestly, you've given me such food for thought. So thank you for doing the research. But also thanks for following it through and actually writing it up and get it to publication.
因为我们当中的许多人，包括我自己和我的博士论文，最终都没有发表。是的，为你点赞，因为这需要大量的工作，需要巨大的承诺。谢谢你。我认为，从我的角度来看，争论的焦点在于，如果我们有……我的意思是，我们非常幸运能够遇到这样一种假设，即有人因此受到虐待。我们很幸运，我们遇到了支持这一点的假设。我认为……
Because so many of us, myself included with um my doctoral thesis just never got to publication and yeah well done to you because it's a lot of work it's a lot of commitment thank you it was um i think i think the argument from my point was that um if we had i mean we were really lucky to meet the hypotheses that there are people being abused for this we were lucky that we met the hypothesis for that I think that it would have been
这些人可能会说他们在研究目标方面很不走运，基本上确实如此。但我认为，由于我们能够……因为我们不仅与 Faithless 合作，我们还与英国人道主义者协会合作……你也有一个很好的样本，这是一个很好的样本量，你有……是的，我们与皮亚·塔沙基金会（Pia Tasha Foundation）合作，我们还得到了一个全球样本，所以这不仅仅是一个国家面临风险，这是贯穿整个……是的，我认为
those people might have said they're unlucky in terms of research goal basically true but I think the fact that we were able to, because not only did we work with faithless we were a humanist uk we were you've got a good sample as well it's a nice size sample you had yeah we were with the pia tasha foundation and we got a worldwide sample as well so this isn't just really one nation is at risk this is you know throughout the entirety yeah i think that
如果把那些挺身而出的受害者的名字隐去，不把他们的故事推进到发表阶段，那就是对他们的辜负。而且它是第一篇这方面的研究，这简直是锦上添花，因为我们基本上可以为之大声疾呼了。我太喜欢它是第一篇了，因为这实际上让每个人都觉得不那么孤单了。我确信所有的研究参与者，
it would have been a disservice to the victims that put their name forward to have not have pushed it forward for publication. And the fact that it's the first one is just the icing on the cake, really, because we can basically shout about it. I love that it is the first one because actually it makes everybody feel less alone. I'm sure all of the research participants,
你知道的，都能看到副本，并且因此感到自己的经历真正得到了认可和倾听。但随后你知道，对于像我这样的临床医生来说，我可以提供证据。你知道，我可以说：“2020 年，你知道吗？你读过那篇论文吗？那太棒了。”你知道，成为其中一员感觉真的很好，但它将会……它将会继续发声，并将继续发声，以支持临床医生，同时也帮助客户感到被倾听、被理解、不那么被孤立和孤独。所以这真的很……你能对它有这样的反应，因为我认为这正是……我认为这项研究的接下来几步，就是朝着这个方向发展，
you know, have access to copy and feel really validated and heard because of that but then you know for clinicians like me I can evidence it you know I can I correct 2020 you know have you read that paper um that's amazing you know that's a really you know it's really nice to be part of that but it it's gonna it's gonna speak and it's gonna keep on speaking um to support clinicians but also help um clients feel heard understood and less isolated and alone so it's really you've had that response to it because i think that that's what is i think i think the next steps for this piece is is that's that's where it's headed in relation to
让越来越多的专业人士越来越意识到这一点：“原来这里存在着一个我们以前不知道的领域，好吧，我们该怎么做？”我认为，拥有像你这样的专业人士说：“这真的很有趣，我很高兴它吸引了我的注意力”，这将使它获得比原本更多的关注。希望它随后获得的关注能够转化为诸如政策、程序、影响政府和立法之类的事情。所以，是的，我真的很兴奋。是的，我也是。干得好，哈里，非常感谢你今天同意与我交谈，让这个故事更多地为人所知，同时也聚焦于心理健康。
getting more and more professionals becoming more and more aware of this exists here's an area we didn't know okay what do we do about it and i think that having professionals like yourself go that's really interesting i'm glad it peaked my peak my you know attention that it will gain more than what it would have done and hopefully the attention it can then gain will then work towards you know things like policy and procedure and kind of influencing governments and legislation and things like that as well so so yeah i'm really i'm pretty stoked yeah well me too well done good job harry and thank you so much for agreeing to talk with me today and to kind of get this story out there a bit more with a bit with mental health focus as well
太感谢了。不客气，谢谢邀请。不客气。感谢收听，希望你觉得非常有趣。我可以一整天都听哈里说话，感谢哈里同意让我将这次访谈分享为播客节目，因为这仍然是一个需要广为人知的极其重要的信息。如果你愿意，你可以查阅他的研究论文。我会在节目文稿中找到相关的链接。所以，别忘了我们的“有抱负的心理学家集体”（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）很快就会上线。一旦可用，我会立即向大家更新。
um thank you so much no worries thank you for having me you're welcome thank you for listening i hope you found that really interesting i could listen to harry all day and thank you for harry for giving his consent for me sharing this as a podcast episode, because it's still a really important message that needs to get out there. And you can access his research paper if you would like to. I will find a link in the show notes for that. So don't forget we have the Aspiring Psychologist Collective coming very soon. I will update you on that as soon as it's available.
“临床心理学家集体”（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）也已经上线了。在整个申请季，我将保持会员资格开放，以便你可以随时加入。所以那里有很多精彩内容。我们有研究诊所、有 CBT 教学和个案构思、有与我的实时 Zoom 互动，还有每周向我提问的问答机会。在申请季期间，我们还提供为期八周的免费实时正念课程。所以有太多的内容正在进行，所有这些都只需每月 30 英镑的订阅费，而且你还可以补看至今为止错过的所有内容。如果你有任何问题，随时告诉我。否则，非常期待在
The Clinical Psychologist Collective is available too. And across this application season, I am leaving the membership open so that you can dive in at any point that you would like to. So there's loads going on there. We've got a research clinic, we've got CBT teaching and formulation, we've got live Zooms with me as well as weekly opportunities to ask me anything and during application season we've also got a free eight-week live mindfulness course as well. So there is so much going on and it's all for the monthly price of £30 a month and you can catch up on everything you've missed so far as well. If you've got any questions, give me a shout. Otherwise, very much looking forward to catching
《有抱负的心理学家》播客的下一期节目中与你相聚，该节目将于周一早上 6 点准时发布。如果你对播客想播出的内容或者你想让我制作的内容有什么想法，请务必告诉我，你可以通过私信联系我，或者在我网站的播客页面留言。网址是 goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk 斜杠 podcast。然后你可以通过那里的链接填写表格。快来在社交媒体上与我联系吧。我喜欢帮你们庆祝，并成为你们生活中发生的事情的一部分。我在大多数地方都是“玛丽安·特伦特博士”（Dr. Marianne Trent），而且我想说我最常出没的地方是领英（LinkedIn）。再次感谢你的收听。希望你
up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will land with you at 6am on Monday. If you've got any ideas for what you'd like to feature in the podcast, or content you'd like me to make, then please do let me know either by slipping into my DMs, or by letting me know on the podcast page of my website. So it's goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And then you can follow the links there to fill in the form. Do come and connect with me on socials. I love helping you celebrate and being part of what is going on for you. I am Dr. Marianne Trent in most places and I'd say I hang out most often on LinkedIn. Thank you once again for listening. I hope you
觉得这非常有用。如果你在 YouTube 上观看，请点赞并订阅，顺便在几集视频下方给我留个评论。如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，请务必评分和写评价，因为这有助于我们接触到更广泛的听众。非常感谢。我们很快再见。拜拜。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。充满了能够帮助你获得资格认证的经验与教训。快来看看吧。它就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。
found this really useful. If you're watching on YouTube, please like and subscribe and bung me a comment in a few of the episodes whilst you're there. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts, please do rate and review as it helps us to reach a wider audience. Thank you so much. Catch up with you very soon. Bye. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective
如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。伴随着这档播客，我觉得很开心。你将走上获得资格认证的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主讲的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫雅娜（Jana），是一名规培心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。到达这一目标有如此之多的不同途径，这让我感到十分惊奇，而且并没有哪一种是成为心理学家的唯一完美方式。这让我充满了信心，让我知道我并没有做错，也减轻了我自己的压力。
If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide. With this podcast, I feel sad. You'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Turris My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把这本书放下了。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你看这本书，好让自己安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，就绝不会把书放下。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。